اتهم الدفاع المدني في شمال السوري منظمات
الامم المتحده بالتقصير في الاستجابه
لكارثه الزلزال وتسييس تقديم المساعدات
للمنكوبين من جانبها اكدت المنظمه الامميه
ان نقص التمويل هو العائق الاكبر امام
تقديم المساعدات للسوريين ضحايا الزلزال
يذكر ان الاف السوريين لا يزالون بحاجه
الى المساعدات العاجله بعد مرور 12 يوما
على وقوع الزلزله
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الاعزاء كان ذاك خبر
حلقتنا ولنا في نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات الى اي
حد جاءت استجابه الاطراف المحليه
والاقليميه والدوليه متناسبه مع حجم
الكارثه التي خلفها الزلزال في شمال
السوري وما الاعتبارات التي حكمت هذه
الاستجابه
وما مدى دقه الاتهامات بتاسيس المساعدات
الانسانيه لضحايا الزلزال في شمال سوريا
وما العوامل التي تحول دون تدفق المساعدات
التي يحتاجها المنكوبون حتى الان
وما هي فرص نجاح المجتمع الدولي في
الاستفاده مما حدث في الشمال السوري
لصياغه ميثاق يحقق استجابه اسرع في حال
وقوع كوارث طبيعيه مشابهه مستقبلا
[موسيقى]
اقل من 180 شاحنه فقط تحمل مساعدات تابعه
للامم المتحده وصلت الى شمال سوريا بحسب
المنظمه وذلك من خلال معبري باب الهوى
وباب السلامه رغم مرور اثنين عشر يوما على
وقوع كارثه الزلزال والتي قارب عدد
ضحاياها في المنطقه سته الاف قتيل وتجاوز
عدد مصابيها عشره الاف وخمسمائه وقد افادت
منظمات انسانيه بان عشرات الالاف من الاسر
التي شردها الزلزال لا تزال تعيش في
العراء او في مواقع مؤقته تفتقر وفقا
لمنظمات دوليه الى مياه الشرب وخدمات
الصرف الصحي التي بات غيابها مهددا
بانتشار امراض خطيره في المنطقه قد تفاقم
حجم الكارثه خاصه وان الزلزال الحق بالغه
بالمنيه التحتيه وشبكات المياه والكهرباء
والصرف الصحي المتداعيه اصلا بسبب سنوات
الحرب
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنى من واشنطن بسام
بربندي الدبلوماسيه السوريه السابق وينضم
الينا من نيويورك الدكتور عبد الحميد صيام
الخبير في شؤون الامم المتحده وابدا معك
سيد بربندي للسؤال عن كيف كانت الاستجابه
ولو انها متاخره يعني حتى الان
اقل من 180 شاحنه من المساعدات وصلت الى
شمال السوري كيف يمكن تقييم
مدى الاستجابه وكميه هذه المساعدات نظرا
للاحتياجات هناك
شكرا استضافه يعني كما ذكرت تقرير كما هو
معروف الان بان حجم الاستجابه لهذه
الكارثه الكبيره يعني على مقياس واحد الى
100 هي صفر لا يوجد استجابه نتكلم عن
ملايين السوريين الواقعين تحت الانقاض
الذين فقدوا كل شيء ومع ذلك لم تستطع
الامم المتحده مع كل الامكانيات والاموال
التي لديها الموجوده للسوريين اصلا في
مناطق التركيه بالوصول الى السوريين او
على الاقل اعطاء المنظمات السوريه المحليه
الادوات الكافيه او اللازمه للتعامل
البدائي حتى لا نقول بالتعامل ككلمه عاديه
لانه فعلا المسائل كبيره جدا والمجتمع
المحلي منظمات المحليه هي غير مهيئه
للتعامل مع هذا النوع من الحوادث الزلزال
الذي يضرب كل مكان في نفس الوقت الخبرات
المتراكمه كانت بالتعامل مع
الطيران النظام طيران الروسي يضرب قريه
معينه وتميزها اما هنا فكان زلزال التجارب
الدوري كان جدا سيء التعامل مع الظرف
السوري كان جدا سيء لا يرقى حتى الى
برايك وبتقييمك سيد برابندي لماذا كانت
الاستجابه سيئه بهذا الشكل
عدد ظروف حتى نكون منصفين رقم واحد ان
كلنا كلنا بوغيتوا بهذا الزلزال يعني لم
يكن هناك شيء مسبقا يهيئ لنا بانه سيكون
هناك مثل هذا الزلزال هذا عامل جدا مهم
النوع الثاني بان تركيا نفسها التي هي مقر
المنظمات الدوليه والمستودعات والى اخره
يعني
كان زلزال على ايديهم قوي جدا فبالتالي
هذه هذا الجزء الثاني الجزء الثالث هو
الجزء السياسي صراحه
الامم المتحده لا تريد ان تدخل الى اراضي
السوريه الا عن طريق معبر واحد
المساعدات لا تستطيع ان تدخل الى هذا
المعبر بسبب الزلزال غير مهيئه الشاحنات
والادوات التركيه صخرت لخدمه الاراضي
التركيه وهذا شيء طبيعي فبالتالي كان هنا
نقص كبير في الامداد الى الاراضي السوريه
هناك شيء سياسي بالتالي بالضروره ان ان
مكتب امم المتحده في دمشق لاعب دورا سلبيا
جدا في
هذه النقطه سناتي على نقاشها بعد قليل
موضوع تاسيس
المساعدات سيد بربندي لكن سانتقل الى
السيد عبد الحميد صيام هل ما قدم من
مبررات من المنظمات التابعه للامم المتحده
يمكن ان يقنع بتاخر وصول اي مساعدات الى
شمال السوري لما بعد سبعه ايام على وقوع
هذا الزلزال
شكرا اخي حسن يعني هناك اسباب موضوعيه يجب
ان نكون منصفين عندما نتحدث عن هذه
الماساه هناك اشياء خارج
نطاق عمل الامم المتحده واكبر من قدراتها
فهذا زلزال اولا بنسبه سبعه فاصل ثمانيه
ولحقه زلزال اخر بالنسبه سبعه فاصل سته اي
انه من اعظم الزلازل التي ضربت البشريه في
اخر قرن وبالتالي كانت دمار شاملا وكبيرا
وعميقا وواسعا لا دوله تكون مستعده لمثل
هذا الدمار النقطه الاخرى وهو انه ضرب
الساعه الثالثه صباحا والناس نيام ولذلك
كانت فرص النجاوى والهرب القليله جدا نقطه
اخرى انه كان مسموح فقط للامم المتحده ليس
لانها لا تريد كما قال الزميل لكنها مجبره
الا تستخدم الا باب الهوى فقط لان هناك
قرار مجلس امن اعتمد في التاسع من يناير
من هذا العام لمده سته اشهر يسمح باستخدام
باب الهوى لادخال المساعدات الانسانيه
والطريق الى هذا المعبر تدمر واستغرقت
الفرق الاصلاح يومين كاملين يعني تاخرت
وصول اول شحنه
اعتراض حتى نعم السيد عبد الحميد ايضا
سنناقش هذه النقطه في اطار تاسيس هذه
المساعدات كما ورد على لسان اكثر من مسؤول
ولكن كان هناك يعني اعتراف من مسؤولين في
في الامم المتحده مسؤولين عن ملفات اغاثيه
وانسانيه ان الامم المتحده والعلم خذل
الشعب السوري في هذه المحنه يعني كان هناك
اعتراف لان الاستجابه لم تكن على قدر ما
يجب ان تكون او على قدر هذه الماساه
انا اتفق ان كان هناك تقصير تقصير من
الامم المتحده ومنظماتها الانسانيه التي
لم تكن جاهزه
لتوفير كل المستلزمات فورا وبدون اهدار اي
وقت هذا جزء لكن ايضا كان هناك تقصير من
المجتمع الدولي الدول هذه المناطق منطقه
الزلزال تحتاج الى معدات ثقيله
للبحث تحت الركام وازاله الركام والبحث عن
الناجين هذه ليست في يد الامم المتحده هذه
خارج قدرات الامم المتحده هناك دول عظمى
لديها هذه الامكانيات لم تقدمها للشمال
السوري ولكن اسرعت لتقديمها او مساعده
الجانب التركي لان هناك بنى تحتيه جاهزه
وامكانيات الوصول اسهل ولا يوجد اي عقبات
تعرفون ان سوريا كانت تخضع للعقوبات يعني
عقوبات ايضا هذه النقطه ايضا هذه النقطه
جزء جزء من نعم ايضا هذه النقطه موضوع جزء
من التسيس يعني كان كان الامر معقد بحيث
لم تستطع او لم يستطع حجم هذه الماساه ان
يتجاوز تلك العقبات وتلك العراقيل اود
الاشاره هنا الى ان مدير الدفاع المدني
السوري في شمال البلاد في شمال سوريا
اتهمه وكالات الامم المتحده بتاسيس
المساعدات من خلال طلبها موافقه نظام بشار
الاسد على فتح المعابر واشار المسؤول الى
وجود ما سماه سندا قانونيا يتيح للامم
المتحده تنفيذ عمليات عبر الحدود من دون
الحاجه الى تفويض من الدول او حتى من مجلس
الامن هذه النقطه ساطرحه عليك ايضا سيد
عبد الحميد صيام الم يكن بالامكان هنا
التحرك
وفقا لسند القانون الذي اشار اليه
مدير الدفاع المدني في هذا المجال
يعني لا اعرف اي سند قانوني هناك قرار
مجلس امن واضح اعتمد بالاجماع في التاسع
من يناير لا تستطيع دوله ان تخترق هذا
القانون لكن التقصير جاء من اعضاء مجلس
الامن لماذا لم يجتمع مجلس الامن منذ
الزلزال حتى يوم الاثنين اللاحق اي بعد
ثمانيه ايام هذه نقطه تلام فيها الدول
لماذا لم تتحرك المجموعه العربيه لماذا لم
يتحرك الاتحاد الروسي الحليف الاول لسوريا
لعقد اجتماع فورا لحد الان لم يتفق مجلس
الامن على عقد جلسه مفتوحه هناك حديث الان
تسرب الينا من البعثه المالطيه التي تراس
مجلس الامن الان يكون هناك حديث حتى يكون
هناك جلسه مفتوحه لمجلس الامن للبحث ونشر
المعلومات حول عمق الماساه اذا التاخير
كان من الدول بعضها مقصود في تعطيل العمل
مجلس الامن لو اجتمع مجلس الامن من الساعه
الاولى
واقر فتح المعابر بالاتصال مع والتنسيق مع
النظام السوري لكان اختصر يعني ما قلته عن
ان الامر كان مقصود بتعطيل عمل مجلس الامن
يعني هذه النقطه ايضا لافته ومهمه سيد
بربندي
تسييس تسييس المساعدات هل توافق الراي انه
كان بالامكان لو لم يكن هناك قرار بتاسيس
هذه المساعدات ان تكون
الاستجابه اسرع ووصول المساعدات ايسر
بقرارات امميه واضحه
استاذي العزيز انا رح احكي لك كيف السوري
يرى الامور نحن نبعد عن القانون
داخل سوريا يرى ان في سوريا يوجد خمسه سته
جيوش يوجد جيش تركي والاسرائيلي والايراني
والامريكي وجيش النظام هؤلاء لم يطلبوا
مجلس الامن اذن مجلس الامن الى دخول الى
سوريا كل جيش لديه معابر دخول قواته
والخروج منها وادخاله لماذا عندما نحتاج
الى حبه دواء نحتاج اكسوريين الذهاب الى
مجلس امل للقول دخيلكم دخلونا نحب الدواء
او ربطه خبز هذا يعني بالمنطق الارض غير
معقول لديرك كارثه الامم المتحده لديها
مستودعات لديها يمكن ليس لديها معدات
للانقاذ ولكن لديهم الاكل الشرب الادويه
البطانيات الخيام جاهزه لديهم كان هناك
امكانيه كبيره لاعطاء هذه المواد البسيطه
البدائيه لانقاذ الناس الذين خرجوا من
الزلزاب ليس انقاذ الناس الذين تحت
الانقاذ الشهداء الذين تحت الانقاض
البطوله التي نتكلم عليها كان هناك نقص في
الفيول المازوت للمعدات التي تحتاجها
الدفاع الوطني
ومنظمات الخبز البيضاء وغيرها التي موجوده
عند الامم المتحده لم يتم اعطائهم لها نحن
لا نكن نطالب الامم المتحده بخرق قانون
الدوله لاننا نعرف منظمه دوليه ولكن الذي
كنا نقول لهم انهم استودعتكم جاهزه
المنظمات السوريه المحليه موجوده اعطونا
فقط نحن نوزع وهذا الذي رفضوه نحن لم
نطالبه حتى بالدخول العبور حدود او خارج
اي قانون فالسوري على الارض يرى ان هذه
الجيوش لماذا لماذا
لانه شوف في لماذا هنا عدد اسباب في جزء
منهم يقول باننا لا نريد ان نخطب تركيا لا
نريد ان نعطي كثير من المساعدات اعلنا الى
سوريا حتى لا يغضب الراي العام التركي لا
تغضب الحكومه التركيه لانهم يحتاجون الى
هذه المساعدات هذا الجزء الجزء الثاني
مكتب المتحده في دمشق ويقول عليكم ان
تكونوا حاضرين علينا الا نغضب النظام هذه
ماساه طويله يعني علينا ان نبقى في تواصل
جيد مع النظام لان هذه طويله الامد هذه
النقطه هذه النقطه التي التي ذكرتها كان
هناك عفوا سيد براغندي هذه النقطه التي
ذكرتها تحديدا ما اود ان اضيء عليها يعني
لماذا الامم المتحده تقول لا نريد اغضاب
النظام بموضوع بموضوع المعرفه وهنا الجانب
السياسي في القصه
نحن نحن بالسوريين بتعاملنا مع منظمات
الامم المتحده لدينا تاريخ سيء جدا جدا
معهم هم ينظرون دائما بان يجب ان تكون
نقطه البدايه هي ارضاء النظام ومن ثم
العمل عليه فبالتالي اي خطوه تقوم بها اي
من منظمات الامم المتحده لغازيه حتى في
شمال سوريا حتى الموجوده في تركيا يتم
التشاور فيها مع مكتب امم المتحده في دمشق
التي تهويه تشاور النظام السوري وتاخذ
رايه وتتبناه هذا نراه منذ حلب الى اليوم
يعني خلال ست سبع سنين
بعضهم يقول انهم يريدون ان يبقوا يحترمون
معاشاتهم اذا اذا عارضوا نظام النظام
سيطردهم وياتي بغيرهم الموضوع جدا بسيط
احيانا يكون شخصي احيانا يقولون بان منظمه
الامم المتحده لا تعمل الا من خلال
القانون الدولي الذي يعترف بشرعيه النظام
وبالتالي عليهم التعاون ما هو والتنسيق
معه وهنا يكون هناك بطئ في التعاطي النظام
يريد ان تاتي كل المساعدات اليه وهو يق
توزيع بدون اي رقابه دوليه بدون اي اشراف
خارجي بدون اي اي شيء يعني يوزعه بطريقه
التي تناسبه الامم المتحده في مناطق
النظام تعطيه ما يريد لا يجد رقابه امميه
على طريق الصرف اموال الامم المتحده في
مناطق النظام حتى الزلزال بعد الزلزال لا
نعرف كيف يجري فبالتالي هناك كثير من
الامور الشخصيه الدوليه الاداريه التي
كلها تجتمع على ان دور الامم المتحده في
سوريا هو دور سلبي جدا ربما هناك تعليق من
عبد الحميد صيام على على
ربما هناك تعليق من عبد الحميد صيام على
على ما قلت ولكن ولكن عفوا سيد عبد الحميد
الامم المتحده وعلى لسان مناسقها الانسان
في سوريا مهند هادي اكد في حديث للجزيره
انها تواجه تحديات جمه في اغاثه منكوبي
الزلزال في شمال سوريا اهمها نقص التمويل
بعض الدول الغربيه تواصلت معنا
وهم في نيه وفي صدد تقديم المساعدات
الماليه لكن 400 مليار 400 مليون دولار هو
مبلغ كبير واضف الى ذلك سيدتي نحن بحاجه
للعمل الانساني الاخر في سوريا اللي هي
الاستجابه
لظروف
متطلبات الحرب ونتائج الحرب والازمه اللي
يمر فيها باقي سوريا نحن نهاجه بحاجه الى
اكثر من اربعه مليار دولار
اذا السيد عبد الحميد كما يقول السيد هادي
المساله بالدرجه الاولى هي نقص التمويل
قبل ان ندخل في الاعتبارات الاخرى
اللوجستيه او حتى السياسيه
دعني اوضح نقطتين اولا هناك وضع كارثي في
شمال سوريا قبل هذا الزلزال هناك اربعه
مليون ومئتي الف سوري بحاجه الى مساعدات
وهناك نداء انساني لتمويل هذه المساعدات
والتي تصل الى اربعه مليارات دولار اصلا
قبل قبل الزلزال اذا اضيف الى هؤلاء خمسه
ملايين الان هناك تسعه مليون ونصف سوري
بحاجه الى مساعدات وهذه مبالغ هائله لا
تاتي فورا يعني الامين العام اطلق نداء
لجمع 397 مليون للاحتياجات الانيه الان
وهناك اجتماع اخر في مارس
للدول المانحه لتمويل برامج الاغاثه على
المديين المتوسط والبعيد في الشمال السوري
النقطه الثانيه
العظام مجلس الامن يعني يتوسلون الى
السفير الروسي للسماح لابقاء معبر واحد
مفتوح وهو باب الهوى السفير الروسي كان
سيستخدم الفيتو كان يريد ان يطبق كل ان
يغلق كل المعابر الى سوريا ويكون التعامل
مع النظام وبعد مفاوضات طويله اقتنع او
اقنع السفير الروسي بابقاء هذا المعبر
الوحيد مفتوحا امام المساعدات الانسان
لمده سته اشهر فقط لذلك ما كان بامكان
الامم المتحده ان تتجاوز هذا القرار
وبالتالي ذهب مارتن جرفس الى تركيا ثم الى
الشمال السوري ثم الى دمشق ويا ليت انه
ذهب الى دمشق فورا لضمان الموافقه على
معبرين جديدين وللعلم المعبر الاخر وهو
معبر الراعي ما زال غير
قابل لاستقبال المساعدات يعني لم يبدا
العمل سبعه عشره شاحنه فقط دخلت من باب
السلامه فقط لانه بحاجه الى تاهيل الان
يعني هناك ظروف اصعب من قدره الامم
المتحده
تقصد هنا روسيا عندنا من الدول عندما ذكرت
انه
كانه منع مجلس الامن من الانعقاد لبعد
ثمانيه ايام من وقوع الكارثه من الذي عطل
ومنع اجتماع مجلس الامن
يعني لا استطيع ان اقر لان يعني بالتاكيد
لكن اللوم يقع على رئاسه المجلس مالته على
المندوب العربي الوحيد في المجلس وهي
الامارات لماذا لم تدعو الى جلسه طارئه
على المجموعه العربيه لماذا لم تدفع بهذا
الاتجاه وهذا ايضا تقصير من العرب يعني
هناك تقصير في سوريا من الانظمه العربيه
التي لم تهرع لايصال المساعدات فورا بدون
اذن احد مطار حلب كان مفتوحا وكان بامكان
ارسال المساعدات كما فعلت الجزائر
قبل ان اعود واختم معك تعليق سيد بربندي
على هذه النقطه
شوف الجميع يحاول تسييس هذه المساعدات
للحصول على اكبر مكاسب سياسيه النظام
السوري روسيا المجتمع الدولي حتى بطرق
مختلفه النظام ليس له مصلحه بان يتم فتح
هذه المعابر لان ذلك يعني ان هذه مساعدات
لن تاتي عن طريق دمشق وبالتالي الروسي
والايراني هم وراء النظام بهذا التصور كل
المساعدات يجب ان تاتي عن طريق دمشق
لتتبعتي الى ادلب او الى مناطق الاخرى
المتضرره فبالتالي تمديد هذا او عدم طلب
النظام من الامارات على الاقل ان عقد
بالطبع بتوافق روسي عدم عقد جلسه هو خدمه
سياسيه للنظام تزداد حجب المعاناه يزداد
حجم الطلب بحيث الدول تاتي تترجى النظام
ان ادخل المساعدات وهذا الذي تماما
هذه تجربه الى اي مدى يمكن ان يستفاد من
هذه التجربه في صياغه
ميثاق معين او اليه
اقرار اليه معينه لحالات من هذا النوع
تتجاوز العوامل السياسيه وحتى نقص التمويل
من قبل الامم المتحده
يعني اولا هذه ليست الكارثه الكبرى
الوحيده يعني تذكرون كارثه تسونامي في
ديسمبر 2004 التي شملت اكثر من عشرين دوله
وتذكرون
الزلازل الكثيره واخرها فيضانات باكستان
التي اغرقت ثلث البلاد
الامم المتحده بحاجه الى اعاده النظر في
موضوع المساعدات الانسانيه ارتفعت نسبه
الكوارث الطبيعيه بعد عام 1990 الى اليوم
بنسبه 15
بالمئه اي هناك بسبب طبعا الاحتباس
الحراري والتغير المناخي كثره الكوارث
الطبيعيه زادت عددا وقوه لذلك الامم
المتحده بحاجه الى انتاج تصور جديد ويفضل
ان تكون هناك منظمه خاصه ان يفصل مكتب
منسق الشؤون الانسانيه لتصبح منظمه منفصله
بعيده عن التسييس مثل مثلا
تم
المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه بعيده عن الامم
المتحده وهناك منظمات اخرى منفصله لكن
تنسق مع الامم المتحده هذا هو المطلوب
الان شكرا لك عبد الحميد صيام الخبير في
شؤون المتحده من نيويورك وشكرا لبندي
الدبلوماسيه السوريه السابق كان معنا من
واشنطن انتهت حلقتنا شكرا والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]